en nuestro último vídeo estuvimos
trabajando con la curva de el margen de
ingresos que era esta curva que teníamos
aquí de hecho era una recta y esta recta
tenía la propiedad de que tenía el doble
de pendiente que la recta de la demanda
y más aún esta idea se puede generalizar
porque siempre se cumple esta propiedad
en algún vídeo yo tengo con alguna ayuda
de cálculo la demostración de que esto
se cumple ahora bien también cabe
mencionar que esta curva de margen de
ingresos es muy distinta a que si
tuviéramos la misma curva de margen de
ingresos pero con una competencia
perfecta si tenemos una competencia
perfecta entonces se fija un precio
común en el mercado y todos los
competidores deben de vender al mismo
precio supongamos que para
ejemplificarlo le ponemos un precio de
tres mil pesos por tonelada entonces la
curva del margen de ingresos se vería
como una recta constante es decir no
importa la cantidad de toneladas de
naranjas que nosotros vendamos el precio
siempre va a ser tres mil pesos por
tonelada no hay monopolios no hay formas
de salirse del precio que fijaron todos
bueno eso sería el caso si tuviéramos
una competencia perfecta pero bueno si
estamos en un monopolio los precios
varían porque tú eres el único productor
en el mercado es decir el precio va a
cambiar con respecto a la cantidad que
nosotros produzcamos ahora bien si
seguimos con esta visión la pregunta
correcta va a ser cómo encontrar una
producción óptima la cual maximiza las
ganancias si nosotros fuéramos
economistas justo atrás de eso and
haríamos como poder encontrar aquella
producción que maximiza las ganancias
pero ojo lo que nosotros queremos es
maximizar la ganancia no maximizar el
ingreso hay que tener cuidado de hecho
si quisiéramos maximizar el ingreso ya
hubiéramos acabado desde hace varios
vídeos pues el ingreso máximo se va a
obtener cuando nosotros tenemos tres
toneladas de naranjas por lo tanto
también hay que tener cuidado qué pasa
con la función del costo supongamos que
tenemos una función del margen del costo
o con el margen del costo muy parecida a
ésta entonces vamos a repasar el
escenario nosotros tenemos un monopolio
de naranjas somos los únicos productores
de naranjas
el mercado y tenemos esta curva de
margen de costos del mercado o si lo
vemos de otra forma esta es la curva de
oferta del mercado la cual nos dice para
cada precio cuál es la oferta del
mercado que nosotros tenemos por ejemplo
si el mercado quiere producir una
tonelada extra entonces el mismo precio
que tengo que dar está dada por el
margen de costo bueno a estas alturas
del vídeo vamos a pensar en cuánto
debemos producir suena lógico que al
menos produzcamos algo y además lo
podemos vender a un buen precio de hecho
si nosotros producimos cerca de una
tonelada entonces lo podemos vender a
seis mil pesos tenemos un margen de
ingresos muy parecido a esa cantidad y
el margen de costos es muy bajo entonces
seguramente tú vas a decir voy a seguir
produciendo porque la curva del margen
de ingresos sigue siendo mayor a la
curva del margen de costos hasta que
llegamos a un cierto punto si nos damos
cuenta existe un punto en donde las dos
curvas se intersectan justo en el
momento en el que nosotros producimos
dos toneladas naranjas y bien se cuenta
que después de ese punto vamos a perder
es decir si hacemos dos toneladas con
una naranja
vamos a perder porque la curva de margen
de costos toma valores más grandes que
la curva de margen de ingresos después
de ese punto esto quiere decir que
nuestra ganancia empieza a disminuir por
lo tanto no hay que pasarnos de esta
cantidad de dos toneladas más aún si
nosotros nos fijamos en un punto que
esté a la izquierda de estas dos
toneladas nos fijamos en un punto que
está a la izquierda estas dos toneladas
podemos ver que la curva de margen de
ingresos es mayor a la curva de margen
de costos por lo tanto si nosotros
queremos producir una cierta cantidad de
naranjas lo óptimo sería producir una
cantidad menor a dos toneladas de
naranjas y más aún si nosotros nos
fijamos en este punto en donde tenemos
dos toneladas esto es con un punto de
equilibrio ya que se intersectan dos
curvas tanto la de margen de costo como
la de ingresos ahora bien este punto de
equilibrio sería muy distinto si
tuviéramos una economía perfecta
recuerden si no fuéramos un monopolio
pues este punto de equilibrio estaría en
el punto 33 justo aquí es decir cuando
nosotros producimos tres toneladas
naranjas pues recuerden que la curva del
margen de ingreso
era una constante en la recta p igual a
3 y en el punto en donde se intersectan
con la curva de margen de costo es este
que tenemos aquí ahora regresando a
nuestro caso original a nuestro
monopolio el punto en donde se
intersectan las dos curvas de margen de
costo y margen de ingresos este de aquí
es el que nos habla de una pérdida
irrecuperable de eficiencia y esta
pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia no
es para espantarse de hecho es buena
para nosotros como monopolio aunque tal
vez no sea tan buena para la sociedad
pero al menos en este ejemplo es buena
para nosotros pero bueno retomando esta
gráfica vamos a definir algunas cosas yo
quiero definir qué es el excedente del
consumidor el excedente del consumidor
es el área que hay entre el precio y la
curva de demanda está abajo de la curva
de demanda y arriba del precio es este
área que está aquí ahora bien el
excedente del producto que es
esencialmente lo que intentamos
optimizar es el área que está abajo del
precio y que llega hasta la curva del
margen de costo esta área es el
excedente del productor y por último
como teníamos una pérdida irrecuperable
de eficiencia ésta también se ve como un
área
esta gráfica es esta de aquí ahora bien
si quisiéramos eliminarla tendríamos que
aumentar el excedente del productor y
disminuir el excedente del consumidor
por esta misma razón aparece esta área
de la pérdida irrecuperable de
eficiencia y es obvio que esta pérdida
irrecuperable de eficiencia le da más
valor al productor es decir al monopolio
y le da mucho menos valor al consumidor